ready you gotta okay
it's time for day drinking with Seth and
lizzo it's really tequila late night
host Seth Meyers got to do something
that is now on my bucket list day
drinking with lizzo you're not just an
artist you're a fashion icon that's
something you insisted I say about you
and lizzo's Twitter video post day
drinking is proof of just how crazy
things actually got happy
behind
life
the first game was guessing what events
Liza wore different outfits to but
before the tea it was some wine that was
spilled
happy holidays
yes slap it slap it
yes you gotta slap it like that even
after all of that I have to say my
favorite segment still had to be Truth
Hurts Seth's specially made truther shot
segment named after her iconic song
what's the worst thing you've ever done
on a plane
oh I feel like that's the face of a
woman who knows exactly what it is now
will she tell us will she tell us or
shall she do the shop
I have to respect
you know what I'm saying it's safe to
say that this day drinking segment was
full of holiday spirit even while Seth
and lizzo pretended to break up with
each other you got like Elvis like
Elvish like Christmasy eyes so I'm in
the spirit you have a little freckles
yeah it's beautiful you're cheating on
me Merry Christmas we're gonna live
forever